there's tobacco and marijuana in there
that's all it is
this is elon musk he's the richest man
on the planet with a net worth of over
200 billion dollars he's been involved
in paypal tesla spacex the boring
company open ai and neuralink all while
focusing on his long-term goal of
escaping earth and colonizing mars but
it hasn't always been a smooth road for
him growing up his father tormented him
and he was relentlessly bullied at
school he almost went broke more than
once and incited lawsuits and government
scrutiny he's also come under fire for
his provocative and controversial
activities various outlets have
described him as a troll who got lucky
with his companies he's also started
multiple twitter beefs throughout the
years between electric cars space
rockets and solar batteries at one point
he was even predicted to become the
world's first trillionaire
this is how he went from bullied
schoolboy to startup founder to the most
eccentric billionaire in the world
[Music]
he was born on june 28 1971 in pretoria
south africa his mother mae was a
professional dietitian and model she has
appeared on boxes of special case cereal
and the cover of time magazine his
father errol musk was a south african
electromechanical engineer and property
developer who once owned half of a
zambian emerald mine
after his parents divorced in 1979 the
nine-year-old musk and his younger
brother kimball decided to live with
their father a choice he made two years
after the divorce and subsequently
regretted he'd become estranged from his
father and described him as a terrible
human being who has done almost every
evil thing you could possibly think of
in 1983 at the age of 12 musk sold a
simple game called blastar to a computer
magazine for 500
he described it as a trivial game but
better than flappy bird his school days
were brutal he was once hospitalized
after being beaten by bullies the
bullies threw him down a set of stairs
and beat him until he blacked out
after graduating from high school he
moved to canada with his mother his
sister tosca and his brother kimball and
spent two years studying at queen's
university in kingston ontario he went
to america and finished his studies at
the university of pennsylvania earning
degrees in physics and economics while
studying at the university of
pennsylvania he and his classmate rented
out a 10-bedroom frat house and turned
it into a nightclub the move which he
undertook with his friend was one of his
first entrepreneurial experiments after
graduation he traveled to stanford
university to study for his phd but he
dropped out after only two days deciding
to test his luck in the dot-com boom
that was just getting underway
he never returned to finish his studies
at stanford with his brother kimball he
launched zip2 a cluster of silicon
valley investors helped to fund the
company which provided city travel
guides to newspapers like the new york
times and the chicago tribune while zip2
got off the ground he literally lived in
the office and showered at a local ymca
the hard work paid off when compact
bought zip2 in a deal worth 341 million
dollars in cash and stock earning musk
22 million dollars
in 1999 he started x.com an online
banking company he launched the company
using 10 million dollars of the money he
got from the zip2 sale about a year
later x.com merged with confinity a
financial startup co-founded by peter
thiel to form paypal
in late 2002 he made a fortune when ebay
bought paypal for 1.5 billion dollars as
paypal's single biggest shareholder he
netted 165 million dollars
in early 2002 he founded the company
that would be known as space exploration
technologies or spacex his goal was to
make space flight cheaper by a factor of
10.
spacex's long-term goal was to make
colonizing mars affordable his next
venture was tesla an electric car
company co-founded by veteran startup
exec martin eberhard
he took an active product role at tesla
helping develop its first car the
roadster
in 2006 the all-electric roadster
debuted when musk was serving as tesla's
chairman in 2007 he staged a boardroom
coup at tesla first ousting eberhard
from his ceo seat and then from the
company's board and executive suites
entirely in 2008 with the financial
crisis seriously limiting his options he
personally saved tesla from bankruptcy
he invested 40 million dollars in tesla
and loaned the company 40 million more
not coincidentally he was named the
company's ceo of the same year
right around christmas 2008 he got some
good news spacex had landed a 1.5
billion contract with nasa to deliver
supplies into space and tesla finally
found more outside investors
by june 2010 tesla held a successful
initial public offering the company
raised 226 million in the ipo
to get his finances back on track he
sold shares worth about 15 million
dollars in the offering
his extraordinary career was starting to
get noticed in other circles too most
notably in hollywood he even had a cameo
in iron man 2. by the end of 2015 spacex
had made 24 launches on assignments like
resupplying the international space
station setting lots of records along
the way
in 2016 the spacex falcon 9 made the
first successful ocean landing of a
reusable orbital rocket the falcon heavy
the successor to the falcon 9 and the
most powerful rocket spacex has built to
date completed a successful maiden
launch in february 2018.
the falcon heavy carried a unique
payload a dummy dubbed starman and his
personal cherry red tesla roadster which
were launched toward martian orbit
[Music]
he couldn't stop coming up with new
ideas like the hyperloop a super
high-speed train that travels in a
vacuum tube the hyperloop could
theoretically transport passengers from
los angeles to san francisco in 30
minutes
on december 11 2015 he co-founded open
ai a non-profit dedicated to researching
artificial intelligence and assuring it
doesn't destroy humanity in 2016 he
started the boring company which aims to
dig a network of tunnels under and
around cities for high-speed no traffic
driving
in july 2016 he founded neuralink which
aims to build devices that can be
implanted inside the human brain with
the short-term goal of treating serious
brain diseases and long-term goal of
human enhancement
[Music]
on august 7 2018 he ran into some
trouble when he sent a tweet declaring
he was considering taking tesla private
at 420 dollars per share and had already
secured funding just a few days later
the sec sent tesla subpoenas about the
company's plans to go private and his
comments by september 2018 the sec had
formally filed a lawsuit against him
accusing him of making false and
misleading statements he settled with
the sec which resulted in both him and
tesla paying a 20 million dollar fine
and musk agreeing to step down as
chairman of tesla's board
he's quite outspoken on twitter
throughout the years he started multiple
twitter beefs he called elizabeth warren
senator karen he called joe biden a damp
sock puppet and he keeps forgetting that
bernie sanders is still alive in
december 2019 musk won a victory in
court when a jury ruled he was not
guilty of defaming the british diver
vernon unsworth unsworth had filed a
defamation lawsuit in 2018 after musk
called him a pedo guy on twitter he's
been heavily involved with
cryptocurrency and has been accused of
manipulating the crypto market he hyped
up dogecoin which started out as a joke
he repeatedly expressed his affection
for the token ahead of his appearance as
host of saturday night live its price
shot up then it tanked the crypto market
seemed to soar or plunge based on his
tweets this made the trillion dollar
crypto market chaotic and unsafe for new
investors which garnered unwanted
attention from regulators
spacex had two major milestones in 2020
first in may when spacex partnered with
nasa to complete its first launch of
astronauts into space then in november
spacex completed its first operational
human space flight by sending four
astronauts to the international space
station for a six-month stay tesla also
had a good year on december 21 2020
tesla joined the s p 500 which caused
its stock to soar and the company was
worth over one trillion dollars
recently his long-term spat with amazon
founder jeff bezos has reached new
heights as spacex and bezos's rival
company blue origin have bickered over
nasa contracts and their competing
satellite projects elon musk even
tweeted the silver medal emoji to jeff
bezos when he surpassed him to become
the world's richest person according to
forbes magazine he is still the world's
richest person with a net worth of over
200 billion dollars ahead of jeff bezos
bill gates and mark zuckerberg he may
already be the world's richest person
but some analysts predict he could
become the world's first trillionaire
there's a lesson in every journey to
success what can we learn from elon
musk's rise to the top
although he's controversial and is often
seen as an internet troll there's no
doubt he's an extremely hard-working and
successful entrepreneur
he's often stated that a key factor of
his success is his work rate
he puts a tremendous number of hours
into his work sometimes working upwards
of 120 hours per week his advice to
people is to work twice as hard as the
average person
he explained if other people are putting
in 40 hour work weeks and you're putting
in 100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you will
achieve in four months what it takes
them a year to achieve
some argue that he's nothing special and
just hires great talent to build his
companies while others argue that he's a
modern day genius who revolutionized the
tech industry
what are your thoughts the comment
section in this one will be very
interesting
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you next time